[Music]
so if the new galaxy s21 has a
fingerprint sensor in its screen
and galaxy phones have had it for the
last two years
that should mean that the iphone should
get it
soon the answer has got to be
right in here someplace in case it's not
obvious what i'm doing here
i'm trying to take years of evidence
that samsung's galaxy s smartphones get
cutting-edge hardware
ahead of apple's iphones to figure out
what's going to be in the next iphone
and yes i'm fully aware
that iphones often get or lose features
ahead of samsung galaxy phones
why we would remove the analog headphone
jack
it really comes down to one word courage
so why do this now
well this is the brand new samsung
galaxy s 21
and 21 ultra and while they didn't make
a big splash a couple weeks back when
samsung introduced them
they are great phones and i recommend
them to anyone who wants the best
android phone
but there are three specific hardware
features that will make iphone users
jealous
number one a fingerprint sensor embedded
in the screen
very handy for our mask world starting
right now
one two three in starting now
in number two faster 120 hertz screens
i'll explain what that means in a minute
number three a crazy camera with a 10x
optical zoom
on the highest end model the galaxy s 21
ultra
so let us turn to the evidence to see if
any of it can give us some clues as to
what's next for iphone users
let's start with what samsung had first
water resistance
samsung introduced it first on the
galaxy s5 in 2014
apple added it two years later in 2016
to the iphone 7.
wireless charging samsung introduced it
around the same time with wireless
charging cases for the galaxy s4 and s5
it was integrated in the galaxy s6 apple
added it later in 2017 to the
iphone 8 and 10. it's fair to say
samsung has always been a step ahead on
screens
the galaxy s6 from 2015 and the galaxy
s7 from 2016
had oled screens and the edge versions
of those phones
cut down on the bezels with screens that
stretched all the way to the sides
it wasn't until two years later with the
iphone 10 that apple did something
similar
okay okay now there's a pattern here
now in complete fairness there has been
a long history of samsung following
apple on countless features heck the
entire galaxy line was inspired by the
success of the iphone
just go back to 2011 to the patent
battles where apple said
samsung has chosen to slavishly copy
apple's innovative technology
the company settled the fight in 2018.
samsung paid apple
539 million dollars but there's some
more recent evidence
apple put two rear cameras into the
iphone 7 plus in 2016.
samsung added it two years later in its
galaxy s line with the s9 plus
apple nixed the headphone jack with the
iphone 7. samsung waited a bit
four years later with the galaxy s20 it
said bye bye too
with the iphone 12 in 2020 apple got rid
of the charger in the box
samsung followed quickly with the new
galaxy s21
so what does it mean for the next iphone
getting some of my favorite galaxy s21
features
i think quite a bit let's take a look at
the list again
number one that fingerprint sensor i
just raved about
samsung introduced this first in the
galaxy s10
it didn't work great then but it's now
super fast accurate and more reliable
thanks to a new ultrasonic sensor made
by qualcomm
apple tends to wait on these
technologies so it isn't first
but it's better and with that apple's
been working on
in-screen fingerprint technology and has
considered including both touch id
and face id on the same device two
former apple employees told me
there have been reports that the next
iphone will have this in-screen sensor
too
apple also holds a number of patents
related to this type of in-screen
technology
two were filed in the past year number
two a 120 hertz screen
there's a lot of complicated screen
refresh rate tech behind it all
but it simply means games scrolling and
using a stylus can be much smoother
samsung by the way is one of apple's
display technology providers
and there have been reports that samsung
will be the provider of this sort of
display in the iphone 13.
number three an ultrazoom the samsung
galaxy s21 ultra has
four cameras a wide an ultra wide a 3x
telephoto and a 10x telephoto
the last one is capable of super clear
photos from really far away multiple
reports
say apple is planning to add this to its
pro models at some point
apple declined to comment on all three
of these features and any of its future
iphone plans
but if you believe my wall of evidence
it's all coming
and that's because as winston churchill
once famously said
those who fail to learn about smartphone
launch history
are doomed to not know when their iphone
will get a fingerprint sensor again
yeah i think that's what he said
something like that yeah
now if there was just a way to figure
out when that folding
iphone is coming oof
look at that crease